[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a este programa
especial de france 24 dedicado a uno de
los acontecimientos que definitivamente
marcaron este año 2020 hablamos de las
tan esperadas elecciones presidenciales
de eeuu del pasado 3 de noviembre que
marcaron el fin de cuatro años de
mandato de donald trump y el próximo 20
de enero el demócrata joe biden llegará
a la casa blanca un giro en la política
estadounidense que dispara la inevitable
pregunta que le espera a eeuu al mundo y
a américa latina en particular durante
la era by the end y para comenzar los
invitamos a ver el siguiente informe
demócratas y republicanos se han
alternado históricamente la
administración de la principal potencia
mundial dos fuerzas cada vez más
antagónicas pero con varios elementos en
común que cambiará bajo la presidencia
de joe biden
y muchos nombres de su futuro gabinete
parecen augurar un retorno a la
cooperación internacional y el
multilateralismo la lucha contra el
cambio climático y una apertura a la
diversidad entre otros frentes
postergados por el aislacionismo de la
américa primero de trump
anthony blinken secretario de estado la
elección de este diplomático indica un
retorno hacia el multilateralismo y ya
adelantó que eeuu necesita de otras
naciones alejandro mayorkas de ser
confirmado por el congreso sería el
primer latino en liderar el departamento
de seguridad nacional janet yellen
secretaria del tesoro la economista de
74 años sería la primera mujer en llegar
a este cargo
yibril james será la mujer que logre el
rango más alto en la inteligencia de
eeuu john kerry enviado especial para el
cambio climático estará al frente de
este puesto nuevo dentro del consejo de
seguridad de la casa blanca
no podemos resolver todos los problemas
del mundo solos necesitamos trabajar con
otros países necesitamos su cooperación
necesitamos su asociación porque eeuu en
su mejor momento todavía tiene una mayor
capacidad que cualquier otro país del
mundo para unida a otros y hacer frente
a los desafíos de nuestro tiempo
demócratas y republicanos comparten
ciertas visiones por ejemplo en materia
de política exterior no obstante tienen
matices que no se deben perder
estas diferencias se podrán traducir en
los principales desafíos que joe biden
enfrentará a y respecto de los cuales ya
planteó respuestas cuya concreción
dependerá de que los demócratas alcancen
la mayoría en el senado pandemia de
coronavirus crear centros de diagnóstico
en cada estado desplegar recursos de las
agencias federales economía aumento del
salario mínimo e inversión en energías
limpias racismo y violencia policial
reforma del sistema penal y ayudas a las
minorías medioambiente regreso al
acuerdo de parís política exterior
restablecer los lazos de estados unidos
con sus aliados tradicionales dañados en
los años de trump uno de los mayores
retos será recomponer la relación con
china salud extender el esquema de
seguro público de salud aprobado cuando
era vicepresidente de obama e implantar
un plan para asegurar a un 97% de la
población
inmigración revertir la política de
trump de separar a los niños migrantes
de sus familias suprimir el límite al
número de peticiones de asilo y acabar
con las prohibiciones de viajar a eeuu
para los ciudadanos de varios países de
mayoría musulmana
sin duda el gran desafío de bailén será
gobernar un país en el que prácticamente
la mitad del electorado es seguidor del
populismo nacionalista de donald trump y
muchos están convencidos como lo dice
sin prueba su líder de que el nuevo
presidente ganó las elecciones
fraudulentamente gobernar el país de
trump ese es el gran reto para joe biden
y kamala harris
y vamos ahora a comenzar a analizar
estos posibles escenarios que se abrirán
a partir de la era joe biden y para eso
nos acompaña a telma luzzani ella es
periodista analista internacional
también escritora autora del libro
territorios vigilados cómo operan las
bases militares norteamericanas en
sudamérica del manu sanz y en primer
lugar muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 quisiera
preguntarle en primer lugar en términos
de continuidades y rupturas no que cree
que podemos esperar que suceda bajo la
presidencia de joe biden tanto el
interior de eeuu como en su relación con
américa latina' un tema sobre el cual
usted ha escrito
sí santiago muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por esta entrevista bueno como dice el
informe me parece que el tema del
multilateralismo va a ser uno de los
puntos de diferencia con el gobierno
anterior la gran pregunta es cómo va a
ser yo evaden con una para revertir un
esquema que tan profundamente hizo el
cambio donald trump en cuanto eso en
términos generales en términos internos
creo que el gran la gran tarea va a ser
justamente evitar lo que en la argentina
nos llamamos con el término de grieta
como va a ser para que esa polarización
no frene finalmente cualquier tipo de
política y en términos de la región de
santiago yo creo que hay que mirar un
poco lo que ha pasado en la historia de
eeuu con nuestra región y si vemos si
eso vemos que en realidad de estados
unidos ha tenido objetivos permanentes y
no ha habido grandes cambios por ahí de
matices por ahí de alguna sutileza pero
han habido grandes cambios en relación a
nuestra región así
es muy duro con presiones muy fuertes
con mucha injerencia entonces en ese
sentido yo no soy muy optimista creo que
el golpe por ejemplo han estado en
bolivia hace poquito nos muestra que
eeuu está en la región muy pendiente de
lo que pasa y dispuesto a poner mano
dura si hace falta firma y cuál cree
usted de que no se estaría hablando
según usted del gabinete de hecho wyden
que por ejemplo tiene a mujeres en
cargos a los que nunca habían llegado
sí eso es interesante el tema igualmente
el tema de que sea una mujer de por sí
mismo no hable nada recordemos a cuando
a desarrollo que la mujer pero sin
embargo era tan dura como cualquier otro
de secretario de estado pero bueno me
parece que es un término interesante es
que todos los o por menos los que se
conocen hasta el momento son gente con
muchísima experiencia con experiencia
muchos de ellos en el gobierno de obama
esto me parece que es un punto positivo
también el hecho de que haya intentado
ser multilateral y eso que es una una
buena perspectiva y bueno finalmente
también que tanto en el caso de
venezuela como en el caso de irán que
son los tal vez los más conflictivos y
también es probable que este gobierno de
psoe baile intente suavizar los temas y
ojalá termine o ponga coto a las
sanciones internacionales que creo que
más que daño a los gobiernos les hace
daño a los pueblos
telma luzzani muchísimas gracias por su
participación en este programa especial
de france 24 ha sido un placer contar
con su palabra antes bueno y como por
supuesto uno de los objetivos nuestros
es tener una variedad de voces en este
programa especial saludamos ahora a
fernando posada el ex politólogo y
analista político fernando muchísimas
gracias también a usted por participar
de este programa especial de france 24
quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar qué
escenario cree que se abre al interior
de eeuu con la futura asunción de joe
biden como presidente del país
bueno santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación las 24 creo que eeuu
independiente de siero es que nosotros
en este momento va a estar enfrentando
uno de los procesos históricos de crisis
en términos sociales en términos de
orden en términos de polarización más
profundo de su historia no más cabe
recordar el momento de crisis social de
estados unidos para 1860 para 1960
también esas dos décadas y el proceso de
polarización que vive eeuu actualmente
es quizás comparable en términos de toda
esta organización social esta
polarización política de estos
conflictos raciales que han vuelto a
surgir del problema tan profundo de la
violencia policial del dane situación
empieza a causado por parte de la
decisión de trump de negar los
resultados democráticos es el primer
presidente eeuu en toda la historia que
desconoce un resultado electoral y que
insiste en llamar lo que es fraude luego
aquí estamos ante un escenario en que
bailen como presidente va a tener
tengo retos enormes muy presidente y con
un problema adicional y es que no tiene
una mayoría en el senado decidió unos
retos muy grandes y también tiene una
gobernabilidad muy limitada que tiene a
su favor que como es un político que
lleva más de 40 años de carrera en el
senado en la vicepresidencia conoce
bastante bien el senado y podían tener
maneras de tiempo de maniobrar y de
poder trabajar mejor con ellos pero
ustedes hacía referencia precisamente a
esta crisis social no nuestra invitada
anterior de manos a ni nos hablaba
también de cierta grieta al interior de
eeuu considera usted teniendo en cuenta
que casi prácticamente la mitad del
electorado de eeuu es seguidor de donald
trump es allí donde radica el principal
desafío entonces de joe biden
pues normalmente los presidentes de eeuu
cuando llegan al poder buscan llevar a
cabo reformas que ellos acerquen a
sectores del electorado que no votaron
por ellos eso este históricamente uno
puede encontrar varias varios momentos
en que los presidentes buscan acercar a
electores que no hacen parte de su
sector o de estados que no hacen parte
de los estados con diagonal es una
manera de que los presidentes asignan
por ejemplo la dirección en el futuro y
tener un mayor margen de popularidad lo
que no es otro donde ningún momento fue
ese pero nunca estuvo por encima del 50
por ciento en la imagen de popularidad y
en ese sentido mantuvo una base de
electores muy radicalizada que hasta la
fecha se mantiene vayan tiene el retweet
ante un presidente eeuu de lograr la
mayor popularidad y una mayor inclusión
a los sectores que no votaron por él y
que he hecho en varias oportunidades ha
manifestado que no están de acuerdo con
él como presidente y manifestando que
además es una elección supuestamente
fraudulenta
el reloj eyeos culo de lograr una mayor
inclusión y una gobernabilidad que
incluya a toda la ciudadanía adjuntarle
lo que hizo creemos que fue gobernada
algunas ideas y para los postulados que
estaban muy lejos de incluir a toda la
nación fernando nos queda menos de un
minuto pero no quiero dejar de
preguntarte si consideras que cambiará
algo con respecto a las relaciones de
eeuu y américa latina
de fondo nada en la forma mucho en el
sentido de que por ejemplo con el govern
obama se lograron muchas cosas con cuba
con colombia con la paz de colombia y
más allá de lo narcótico de las
relaciones con américa latina es
fundamental y tenemos la idea de que va
a ir en puede lograr cambios en ese
sentido relaciones más completas
relaciones más armónicas
fernando posada muchísimas gracias por
haber participado de este programa
especial de france 24 dedicado a
analizar el futuro de estados unidos y
del mundo abajo la próxima presidencia
de joe biden ha sido un placer contar
con usted
a nuestra audiencia le invitamos por
supuesto a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en www
puntos francia 24 punto com
[Música]